hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday September 9th 2019 what's going
on how are you today
Oh football Sunday started what I bow to
a Buddha bit had it been at him I just
got done watching the Patriots first
this you know 8:30 9:00 on a Sunday
night out here in the West Coast just
got done watching the game
I thought the Steelers were gonna get us
you know we usually start off slow
you know we've beaten them so many
freaking times in a row I figured all
right this is the time they're gonna get
us and I don't know what happened we
looked we looked really good but it's
also the first game of the year so now
they're gonna be like Jesus Christ you
see what a gigantic fish burger you know
they're gonna do that who knows other
steel is that bad are they [ __ ]
horrible is that why we look good or do
this Steelers just have a [ __ ] bad
game I don't know who the [ __ ] knows all
right but all I know is everybody on
ESPN and all these sports things are
going to lose their minds doing that all
[ __ ] day long all right so you know
we look good we looked good and we'll
see what the [ __ ] happens and then they
said how we have we have a really easy
schedule like the next like five or six
people we play none of them made the
playoffs last year which usually that
means something in a sport but with NFL
and parody and how much people [ __ ]
move around who knows who knows I don't
know I have no [ __ ] idea all I know
is it's a long goddamn year and we'll
see what happens and Antonio Browns
coming to the Patriots who would have
thought who would have thunk it Jesus
Christ condolences to people in
Pittsburgh I know it's like when you get
rid of a [ __ ] player you're like good
ship now he's in Oakland I don't give a
[ __ ] we're never gonna see the guy who
gives a [ __ ] hope he has a great [ __ ]
career out there and then all of a
sudden he goes to the team he can never
[ __ ] beat that's happened to me a lot
of the sports
so I don't know what happened with the
Raiders I talked to a couple people you
know what I think happened I think that
they would they were trying to [ __ ] with
his contract you know they just kept
fighting the guy and anything he [ __ ]
did they were like yeah what did you do
that for that's a $40 fine and then they
had some loophole I guess in the
contract that if he you know can't
conduct unbecoming a profession I don't
what the [ __ ] it wasn't all of a sudden
it voided his contract and they were
gonna try to keep him and and not have
to pay him all the [ __ ] money they
said they were gonna pay him something
like that I don't know I don't pay
attention I don't know I didn't
understand what any the problem was with
what he was doing he didn't like the
helmet you know we yelled at one of the
owners called him a cracker and said
I'll [ __ ] kill you I mean he's on the
Raiders you basically suspended him for
acting like an old-school Oakland Raider
I mean I could see if he played on the
Chargers well they have powdered blue
uniforms and everybody's supposed to be
like hey man let's just throw the ball
around man I don't I don't ride no I
have no [ __ ] idea what happened at
all you know all I know is he [ __ ]
they let him go and now he's on the
Patriots starts next week crazy who
knows but does that automatically mean
that it's gonna be a fit who the [ __ ]
knows but it's a great look for the Pats
cuz even if it doesn't work out with the
guy we only have them for like you know
a year it's like going to Vegas and
meeting some crazy broad the [ __ ] do you
care the second that's all yeah it's
done it's done Jesus Christ she was nuts
you see the size of that knife you know
but that's over you're back in your home
state and nothing happened you know you
got a couple of red marks around your
neck people say what happened you're
like oh I walked into a spider web
that's it you go back to your [ __ ] it
all you know what that isn't it it used
to be it back in the day it used to be
yet but not anymore you combine social
media and and how much women love
vengeance and snooping around there's no
walking away you know when I was a kid
you could [ __ ] walk away [ __ ] went
down you walked away
and then that was it and then maybe on
your deathbed you brought it up you know
not anymore not anymore I saw it's a bad
analogy I have no [ __ ] idea I don't
know what happened but somehow he's on
our team god bless him I hope he enjoys
it here and if he has you know I don't
know any issue whatever he doesn't like
it he's done in a [ __ ] year anyway so
who gives a [ __ ] right I think it works
out for everybody
you know if he has a great [ __ ] year
here then he can ask for the know for
the [ __ ] moon again next year right
you know I know there's a lot of takes
on Antonio Brown coming to the Patriots
but I'm gonna go out on a limb and say
that mine was the most uninformed and I
don't know I don't even think I just
said anything I just didn't know you
could act like too much of an [ __ ]
and get kicked off the Raiders I'm just
I mean I'm old you can kind of do
whatever the [ __ ] you wanted to do it
seemed back in the day come to the game
hat from the [ __ ] bag didn't give a
[ __ ] you know you just go out there and
clothesline a couple of people that's
fine you know can you explain your play
in the first half today I was still
drunk I don't even [ __ ] remember it I
mean though that was the Raiders that I
remember but now it's a different time
you know everybody's got to act like a
country music star and have Family
Values I wish I was the owner of a team
and some [ __ ] player called me a
cracker so they want to rip my [ __ ]
head off I look at all the other players
that's what I'm looking for you guys
over there playing patty-cake shaking
hands with the [ __ ] players on the
other goddamn team after every [ __ ]
game win or lose the next [ __ ] guy
who walks five he doesn't drape my
[ __ ] life I'll tell you right now
Shepard you off the [ __ ] what's a
better Jacksonville
I'll port Jacksonville huh
they got falls in there through an
unbelievable [ __ ] pass for a
touchdown great pass great [ __ ] catch
and he gets [ __ ] hurt what happen to
him I was watching that game early today
when I was in Vegas before I flew back
in time for the Sunday night game with
the Patriots and I was at that was that
[ __ ] tough game man it was a good
game as far as like a lotta anger people
beatin the [ __ ] out somebody got kicked
out of the game for punching this guy in
this [ __ ] helmet you know I think in
the future you know they further protect
kids kids are gonna go to school with
helmets on so when the bully comes up
and hits him he just hits them in the
[ __ ] helmet you know then also with
the cage that you have around your face
people can't see it crying in there
because it hurt your ear we caught you
in the ear hole you know injuries let's
look this up injuries Jax and I don't
know let's go yeah Jacksonville Jaguars
let's see what do we got here
Nick Foles but I almost call him Eric
Falls what the [ __ ] is wrong with me he
only came in and [ __ ] beat the
Patriots you don't remember his goddamn
name bill how old are you and then they
had that mustachioed dude came in
afterwards and he completed like [ __ ]
I don't how many passes in a row but
they started talking about it at five
he's Tyreke Hill got hurt shoulder
injury
what the [ __ ] was the name of his backup
who came in that's six in a row you know
the last guy from six in a row was
twenty left seven in a row the whole
[ __ ] game and is that what America it
was still a decent game sound like poor
Collinsworth than Al Michaels tonight
did a masterful job calling a terrible
game as far as entertainment value made
it but that might that my team wasn't
the Patriots over shut that [ __ ] game
off they did a great job but whatever so
here we go football season has started
it's week one and
don't listen to sports talk radio
because their job is to make anything
you just saw be like that's what's gonna
be for the rest of the year and they're
gonna start saying to us how soon before
so-and-so is on the hot seat what's
going on with the Cleveland Browns you
know they're gonna flip out about
[ __ ] everything and then every
whatever and then whatever good happen
is just gonna be the thing so who knows
you got to wait like four weeks before
you start three weeks four weeks before
you start figuring out who's who's who I
would think I have no idea I'm just
happy my team won and I had a great
weekend I want to thank everybody who
came out in Las Vegas came out to my
show at the Cosmopolitan I had a great
time did like 85 90 percent a [ __ ] that
isn't on my special my new special which
is coming out tomorrow Tuesday this is
tomorrow tomorrow demo September 10th on
Netflix called paper taga are very proud
of it the job that Mike binder did
shooting this thing is it's absolutely
gorgeous I just love the way it looks
and hopefully people like the material
but if you don't like the material just
hit mute and still watch the job that
the great Mike binder did so anyway we
went out and had a bunch of friends show
up to the to the show I work within a
buddy mine Rick Talia that I started out
with way back in the day started out
together in Boston and a great Dean
Delray everybody [ __ ] killed the
crowd was awesome
and so thank you guys so much for that
and then I stuck around for an extra day
and oh no wait no that night we smoke
some cigars and then afterward I smoked
a second one like an idiot but I had to
because Bobby Kelly was in town and me
and Rick D'Elia you know I don't know
last time we got we all three of us hung
out we have back I had a little balcony
on my room little porch area and we just
sat there just [ __ ] laughing our
asses off talking about all of these
[ __ ] horrible gigs all of these
horrible gigs that we did just one after
another
we sat for like three
just taking turns and I thought I had
heard all of Bobby and Rick's stories
you know because I've known him for so
long and they told me a couple like
Bobby told one I'm not I'm not gonna
tell the story cuz I don't know his
story to tell but the humiliation of the
story and I was like dude you never told
me that he goes yeah
tragedy plus time I had to wait til we
will [ __ ] 27 years into this [ __ ]
before I finally felt comfortable enough
to tell it to you but that was a great
time and we stayed I say that was
[ __ ] hilarious I stayed up til like
3:30 in the morning and it finally went
to bed and you know I'm not drinking but
I still woke up the next day feeling
like I got hit by a bus I just can't
stay out that I'm just old I can't do it
and my lovely wife was out there and we
went around you know she went shopping
and we had a good time and just it was
great and then that night we all went to
go see Elton John he's on his farewell
tour and the guy just absolutely [ __ ]
murdered again I played for three hours
72 years old the guy plays for three
hours and if he starts with a hit and
just keeps playing want no opening act
no need for one just one hit after
another for three hours and he comes out
for like an encore like what does he
have left I'm not gonna say what he
played for the Encore but uh played two
songs for the Encore it was [ __ ]
amazing and he saw evens now at 72 you
know I used to jump around all the time
you know doing those [ __ ] handstands
wearing those platform shoes it's funny
when he walked across the stage and you
see the guide like he he [ __ ] gave
people shows for five decades and you
know he's walking like you know he
played a couple seasons in the NFL I
loved seeing old performers like that
man like this guy always understood that
people paid money got a sitter took a
night off saved up their money I'm gonna
give these guys a [ __ ] show and he
was he so now you know he was it was
like when Pedro blessed his fastball he
learned how to [ __ ]
and picture round guys this is same
[ __ ] thing he can't do the handstand
anymore so he had added all this other
crowd interaction like repertoire [ __ ]
that I mean [ __ ] that he'd put into his
repertoire was [ __ ] great and you
know it's mostly older people like me at
the show but there was a ton of young
people too that uh you just see like his
[ __ ] music just transcended and he
had that that [ __ ] guy that [ __ ] his
name the percussionist that I've seen
with everybody he plays a tambourine and
you [ __ ] mesmerised hang on a second
let me look this up Elton John
percussionist Oh ray Cooper this [ __ ]
guy I swear to God I saw him one the
first time I noticed him cuz I didn't
realize he was he started with Elton as
far as his first high-profile gig back
in 72 I just thought he was this hired
gun that they all use because I remember
Clapton had him on his uh that unplugged
special that he did and I remember one
time he was just hitting the tambourine
on two and four and he was doing it with
such level of intensity he was just
holding it like flat like a table and he
just had his hands all spread out like a
[ __ ] spider he was just hitting on
two and four that's all he was doing and
I stopped watching Clapton and I was
watching this guy Jesus Christ I got to
put the [ __ ] and then Nigel Olsson I
finally got to see him play live he had
such a sick drum kit and I had the great
seats where I could watch him play but
of course his ride cymbal was blocking
his face but they did a really good job
where they had a cameraman going around
and sort of filming them as they were
playing but it was you know check that
one off my bucket list cuz a few people
have died recently over the last couple
of years I'm like I never saw him like
David everybody from David Bowie to
Aretha Franklin I'm like [ __ ] I never
saw him you just take him for granted
like
they're gonna be there and it's just
like they either gonna retire or die
I guess dying is hard core retiring that
serious retirement because you know
they're not coming back and when I went
back to my hotel room last night and
it's folks yet another cigar smoke for
cigars in two days so now I'm [ __ ] off
from again stupid man I don't know you
noticed as I'm not drinking and I want
to stay out and hang out and it's just I
have to learn how to do what do you do
with you straightedge people when you go
out and hang out with people you just
stand there watching people consume [ __ ]
what am I supposed to do then you just
start doing [ __ ] out of boredom you want
something to eat yeah what can I get you
of [ __ ] quesadilla then you become a
fat [ __ ] this is it this has to be a
modern-day problem you don't mean back
in the [ __ ] day I think you know you
just were happy that you didn't get
mauled by a bear
or some [ __ ] you know whoever
rightfully owed the land didn't come
back and [ __ ] cut your head off while
you were sleeping I think they I think
he had enough excitement you didn't
catch the plague during the day I don't
know but uh i stoled a good time so
anyways I went back and I was smoking a
cigar I couldn't lay off man the balcony
was [ __ ] amazing and I had a view of
the the where the water goes up you know
the fountains there in front of the that
the old Bellagio is that what the [ __ ]
it was Monte Carlo I can never remember
the names of him anymore and I looked
down the strip and I saw at the at the
Flamingo Donny and Marie were playing
down there I was like man I would love
to go see them because when I was a kid
I remember their variety show then I'm
fascinated with people that have been
doing it that long and still come out
and [ __ ] give it their all and all
that [ __ ] I want to see what that looks
like and I ended up looking him up and
turns out they were just supposed to do
six weeks at the Flamingo and six weeks
turned into a year contract as they sold
so many tickets which turned into
another year another year and now
they've been out there for 11 years
finally they're deciding like going
alright this is it what done and then
there's rumors that they might [ __ ] I
don't know they might they might retire
whereabouts that guy should go out go
[ __ ] and see them you know for those who
don't know who the Osmond family is they
were like I would love to have Keith
Robinson on my podcast and say this
because I don't even know if this true
they were like the Jackson 5 before the
Jackson 5 everybody always talks about
boy bands go now they [ __ ] ripped off
the Jackson 5 that may or may not be
true but as far as I will go on the
Internet
these [ __ ] the Olsen family not
Dolson is that Osman sorry the Osman
shame about those [ __ ] twins the
Osmond family they go back wait a
galettes will see Internet let's ask a
question you'll always get a [ __ ]
answer who was first the Osmonds the
whitest day all its it's here at Jackson
5 ok who started first the Osmonds the
Jackson 5 this was [ __ ] hilarious
alright
the original Osmonds Allen Wayne and
Maryland J started singing in church in
1959 1962 on tour of the West for the
Mormon Church they were discovered by
Disneyland executives of course they
were [ __ ] whitest P they are the
whitest people ever and hired Andy
Williams saw them there and signed them
to appear as regular singers on his NBC
TV show the original Jackson 5 made up
of Jackie Tito Jermaine Marlon and
Michael started out doing shows around
their hometown of Gary Indiana Diana
Ross saw them in 1969 and brought them
to the attention of Motown Records would
sign them The Jacksons appeared on
Williams Show and on The Ed Sullivan
Show yeah so I thought that they were a
little before talk about polar opposite
families that would have been a great
pay-per-view back in the day they should
have had the two of them both do shows
giving it some clever [ __ ] name or
something like that anyway that's why I
want to go see those guys and that's
also why I love Las Vegas as far as you
can see any type of entertainer you want
to see is [ __ ] out there just as far
as where they're at in their career you
know made it crushed it [ __ ] had it
lost it got it back [ __ ] it up you
know
never made it you know or haven't made
it yet if you're gonna look at it
positive you can [ __ ] see all of it
and I don't know that's why it back in
the day he's still like kind of going
from casino casino watching the lounge
people taking in a bigger show watching
somebody that was coming up it's and
just the education you get and I'll tell
you those [ __ ] older people where
everybody tries to blow off I mean Wayne
Newton still doing shows out there I
want to go [ __ ] see that guy because
what happens is then they dying like
[ __ ] I never saw that guy I want to see
what the what the big deal was I want to
know how you know how do you sustain it
how do you keep it going how do you be
like the [ __ ] Tom Brady who just
keeps going did you see those before and
after pictures they stay show tonight on
the leo television there
don't Brady he's in better shape now
than he was back then it makes no sense
I think he just sat around [ __ ]
eating Cheetos in his dorm room and then
they took a picture of him he had no son
nothing pasty is me though maybe was
baby fat he was so goddamn young but
anyway let's get to let's get to
something else here on the podcast what
else can I talk about here Jesus Christ
are twenty minutes you know sometimes
the [ __ ] podcast it just flies by
absolutely flies by so bad why do I have
to keep reminding you guys because this
is you know gonna be an hour-long
podcast here please watch my [ __ ]
special for the love of God so I can
continue living the dream I did say that
Taniya before I went downstairs did my
show at Vegas was like you believe you
know you believe that I can't [ __ ]
believe
I get to do this for a [ __ ] living
again this year this is awesome so thank
you guys for coming out and I got some
brand spanking new dick and [ __ ] jokes
for you when you show up after you watch
my special all right
final score Patriots Steelers 33 to 3 in
defensive Ben Roethlisberger oh I
thought he looked fine Steelers dropped
a bunch of [ __ ] passes a bunch of
passes oh they brought up an interesting
stat - during the game Washington
Redskins there was two strikers in the
80s and the Redskins won the Superbowl
both strikers and I guess Joe Gibbs like
sort of embraced this when they had the
scab players he embraced it and Bill
Parcells [ __ ] hated it and then they
ended up winning the Superbowl just kind
of interesting as far as like his
attitude
Parcells how they eluded to it and it
was also interesting that Washington was
never accused of cheating or having an
asterisk next to their Super Bowl titles
because they are both wandering strikers
because as a patriot fan I can guarantee
you if we have won a Super Bowl during a
strike year there'd be some other
[ __ ] accusation against us because
there's a lot of cuts out there right a
lot of [ __ ] whiny people out there
when it comes to [ __ ] like that
I should talk my old podcast is nothing
but bitching you know be great at doing
his own podcast because if you can just
complain about [ __ ] for an hour you can
you can really make it entertaining you
know who'd be great hosting his own
podcast Louis [ __ ] Hamilton jesus
[ __ ] christ when was the last time
that guy lost a [ __ ] race and he
doesn't [ __ ] mode in a complaint I
literally missed the [ __ ] race and
then I'm trying to see who won I see
Leclerc won again second race in a row
Ferraris won two races Louis Hamilton
still gonna win the [ __ ] championship
right but all the headlines were about
was Hamilton's reaction to [ __ ]
something you look hurt forced him wide
or some [ __ ] well do you know I'm gonna
have a talk with them
wait [ __ ] talking to him talk to the
goddamn storage so whatever the [ __ ] you
call the people that run the race that
dude is such a [ __ ] baby he's an
unbelievable driver he's the [ __ ] one
of the greatest of all time absolutely
absolutely but he is such a [ __ ]
whiner Jesus [ __ ] just take it you're
still on the podium your team's got the
most money you got the best car you're
the best driver you're gonna be fine
jesus [ __ ] christ
dude that guy wins more than me after
the [ __ ] blues with that [ __ ]
hockey that they were allowed to [ __ ]
play you know but I feel like I'm
allowed to do it just because I'm gonna
hold him do I look at all the indoor
higher standard cuz I'm just a fan
that's what they always do right you
know what I apologize to lose him
Hamilton you know what I should say you
know what we should both hang out
because you're just as [ __ ] whiny as
I am every [ __ ] time he's on the
radio whining he's literally whining
during the race and then the [ __ ] oh
the [ __ ] announcers start talking
about treat him like a [ __ ] hot chick
you know he's [ __ ] annoying you know
annoying hot chicks he's [ __ ] I
always watching those flipping back and
forth because I saw what a great match
the final was at the US Open as you can
tell people I don't read books all it is
is just sports and then I have an
emotional reaction to him like it
actually matters I have more [ __ ] I
get more worked up about what the [ __ ]
happened in sports then then how
polluted our oceans are what the [ __ ] is
wrong with me
I can guarantee you something that never
happens no scientist is listening to
this [ __ ] thing unless he's doing a
study on dumb people get mad at [ __ ]
that doesn't matter anyway I'm watching
this [ __ ] the US Open I missed the
whole goddamn thing but I watched some
of the I watched Nadal's
the match he won before he
to the finals I really enjoyed like just
tennis it's so funny people look at it
like it's just this you know non-contact
light sport it's [ __ ] brutal you know
you just [ __ ] running around on the
thing that when you played on the hard
court just being out there at their
[ __ ] age just running side-to-side
for hour after they put mom's up five
our [ __ ] match [ __ ] five hours so
anyway Nadal I was just looking to score
he won a tiebreaker to win the first set
which cruelly crushes is a the opponent
right so the end up one in the next set
I think six three maybe or six four and
then the third set this up and coming
dude like Medved burger some [ __ ] he
wins a tie-break to win his first set in
the third set and then he beats Nadel
like six four in the fourth set now
they're going to a tiebreaker right so
I'm like I gotta watch this cuz if this
kids doing this you know just just out
of out of the psychological advantage
that Nadal had after after he won that
first one and who he is and how many
times he's been there and this this new
kid that he dug down and did forced it
to like to the fifth set I was like I
had to watch it so I was flipping back
and forth cuz the Patriots Steelers had
started and I think you know it's
[ __ ] annoying is I don't underst any
times can they cut to their pouty face
girlfriends in the [ __ ] crowd I kind
of get going to the coach but the coach
isn't allowed to coach so then I just
get to sit there watching I guess the
game is when you look at the coach to
figure out how he really is coaching you
can't tell me you know a [ __ ]
quarterback comes up to the line of
scrimmage called a certain play and then
he recognizes some [ __ ] defense and
he always gives it he just looks at this
[ __ ] wide receivers been playing with
them for a couple years and they already
know what's gonna happen you can't tell
me that coach doesn't not to do that I
mean you can tell me that but I'm not
gonna agree with it even though I don't
know [ __ ] about the sport but they're
always cutting
if pouty face beautiful girlfriends we
sit there with their stupid intense look
in their face oh my god if he loses this
point he won't be able to afford to buy
me as nice a pair of shoes why are you
showing this girlfriend I don't give a
[ __ ]
anyways congratulations to rap is it
Raphael Raphael Raphael Raphael neck
Nadel winning again
Nadel wins championship number what is
it 19
Rafael Nieto beats interdental when US
Open men's final his 19th Grand Slam
I heard Serina got swept but she's
already the greatest of all time with
like 23 or 24 so alright with that let's
write my apologies too before you send
in your [ __ ] complaints to any pouty
faced [ __ ] girlfriend out there if
they cut to you during a barbecue this
weekend and you felt triggered to by the
fact that I would say that all right I
got dropped this in I forgot to read
this during the podcast the final part
of the five cities is up on YouTube shot
by the great Andrew themelis thanks to
everyone who's been watching it and
liking it and all that stuff it's my
European Tour from earlier this year as
I was getting prepared to do my stand-up
special that is coming out tomorrow on
Netflix case I didn't mention it 5,000
times so check it out on YouTube all
right thank you all right here we go
hims wasn't us it was hims 66% of men
start to lose their hair by age 35 well
you're looking at one of them once
you've noticed your hair thing and it
thinning can be too late you know I find
this copy really offensive okay I know
what I look like I don't need it to be
thrown in my face I'm just gonna [ __ ]
sell my soul here and continue to read
this
when the [ __ ] was hymns when I was 35
you [ __ ] [ __ ] alright is that
hairline slowly starting to move
backwards any bald spots yet the best
way to prevent more hair loss is to do
something about it while you still have
some it's time to get a handle on those
precious locks you know what sucks is if
you start balding and your professional
tennis player because as the match moves
on the sweaty you get the more people
see how bald you're going I ask you do
you want a bald spot to pop up on your
hairline or your hairline to recede or
do you want to do something about it
first
for hims calm a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care sexual wellness for men
this is how confident they are with how
much they're gonna regrow your hair they
know it's a two parter no sense having a
full head of hair if your dick doesn't
work right is it like a multivitamin you
take one thing your hair starts to grow
and as your hair is growing your dick
starts standing up you know like the
good guy tag team [ __ ] championship
three quarters the way through the match
when they start turning it around answer
a few quick questions a doctor will
review and if they determine it's right
for you can prescribe you medication to
treat hair loss that is shipped directly
to your door get hair loss treatment
everyone is talking about go get the
hair loss treatment everyone is talking
about featured in GQ Men's Health
Esquire and Playboy to name a few order
now my listeners get started with the
hims complete hair kit for just 5
dollars today right now while supplies
last and subject to doctor's approval
whether or not you can spend five bucks
see the website for full details and
safety information this could cost
hundreds if you went to the doctor or a
pharmacy somewhere else go to for hims
dot-com slash bird that's fo r hims comm
slash bar b you are r for hims calm
slash / there's another one I don't
understand why when you watch a
University of Texas football game and I
was watching the LSU Tiger bad
we finally got a [ __ ] quarterback
last year was not a fluke in that
they're playing an up-tempo offense I
watched the first three quarters before
I went downstairs to do my show and I
had no idea that uh wait what Texas
played the Aggies who the [ __ ] did we
play I can't even remember I watched
someone's [ __ ] Sports Jesus Christ
bill no I thought we played tech did we
play Texas no we didn't I don't remember
who LSU played and I remember who Texas
plate and I watched both [ __ ] games
LSU verse Oh West Texas that was the
same [ __ ] game you know it was
because I was downstairs at the sports
book and I was sitting there on the edge
of my seat going like is Michigan really
gonna lose the [ __ ] army is this
really gonna [ __ ] happen Jesus Christ
and then I was like guilty I was like
you know I was rootin for Michigan I was
like am I not supporting the troops does
that mean I'm siding with with the
evildoers there was a very very
confusing time
so I went when I went down to go do my
show the LSU Tigers what was it to his
24:23 and in the fourth quarter alone
the Tigers scored 22 points and the
Longhorns scored 17 it was like
literally a game within a [ __ ] game
by the way that kid for Patriot fans out
there old school guys Derek Stingley I
was like Stingley you don't hear that
name a lot he is the grandson of the
great Darryl Stingley that played for
the New England Patriots I thought that
was pretty cool and his dad
Derek Stingley senior played baseball
and was I think drafted by the Phillies
I think that's what I read anyway I
don't understand when you played the
Texas Longhorns why am I looking at
Matthew McConaughey you know dressed
like he's doing the sequel to Dallas
buyers club except his character lives
now he's all jacked wearing a [ __ ]
cowboy hat
this sir there's so much [ __ ] when I
watch sports that makes no sense
I'll tell you something else that didn't
make sense right I was on the internet
there and I saw this thing dr. Phil
talks about Kevin Hart you know I love
Kevin Wright so I click on it and he's
standing in front of this old [ __ ] I
don't know 56 57 Chevy Bel Air and he's
talking about Kevin Hart so Mike well
[ __ ] maybe they have an update and the
[ __ ] clip was on TMZ's like he starts
it off he's like uh I don't know Kevin
Hart but I've heard you know from
everybody he's just a wonderful person
and uh I have an old car that also
doesn't have a five-point harness he
doesn't even know him and he's [ __ ] I
don't know what I don't even get it
I don't know Kevin Hart but I have money
in an old car that I wanted to show
everybody it's like you're not a doctor
I don't you think he's just you know
[ __ ] he's like a game show host for
crazy people
I saw a comedian do something like that
one time a comic died in a comic who
didn't know the comic went up and did
the benefit because there was a lot of
industry there trying to make like a
career move I went on stage going you
know I never knew I never met so-and-so
but I heard he was just saying with I
don't know Kevin Hart [ __ ] idiot and
as you can see on my car uh you can't
put a five-point harness on it because
it's a convertible
ladies I have a lot of money
I may be bald but I have a big dick I
was waiting for he just started going to
that level talking about cell that's why
I have a convertible I'm gonna start
weighing in on people like that I don't
even know you know it'd be one thing if
he did it on his own TV show he went out
of his way to get interviewer on
somebody else's [ __ ] TV show
but someone I don't know what the
[ __ ] point he was trying to make me
grant it I watched like the first
[ __ ] age said once he said I don't
know the guy and like why why are you in
your driveway outside your mansion
leaning up against a shiny old car as
you can see this was in the car in the
accident this is my car it has it's a
convertible
I don't know anybody over at Chevrolet
sorry
simply safe everybody I don't know the
name of anybody it's simply safe but
it's something that I would like to feel
on average a burglary happens once every
23 seconds in the u.s. when a home
security system is triggered a lot of
the time police assume it's a false
alarm and the call goes to the bottom of
the list but with simply safe home
security Simonton plea safe home
security Osage has video verification
technology which helps police get on the
scene up to three point five minutes
faster simply safe can visually confirm
that a break-in is happening giving
police precise information about when an
intruder is in a home so I get the
hiccups and whether they're armed I
swear to God I I have some form of
dyslexia because I thought that just
said precise information about where an
intruder is in a home and whether
they're mad instead of armed well he
seems kind of happy-go-lucky let him
take a vase or two and I will wait till
it gets outside all this guy this guy oh
hell he's mad so they have all the
information they need to get there
faster and catch a criminal ASAP simply
safe also protects every door window in
room with in with 24/7 professional
monitoring there's no contract hidden
fees or fine print it won a ton of
awards from CNET to the New York Times
wire cutter pricing the New York Times
is wire cutter prices are always fair
and honest around-the-clock monitoring
starts at just fifteen dollars a month
and from
my listeners simply safe has a huge deal
going on right now go to simply say bird
calm and free shipping and get free
shipping and a money-back guarantee that
simply say bird calm today simply safe
Burt calm why did it say that's simply
safe bird calm today
no it's simply safe si MP Li
SAF Eber calm I don't know who wrote
that copy but oh I used the word today
but I would not have put it there in
that sentence how much [ __ ] money do
you need to make well you got to start
[ __ ] jumping on [ __ ] to show off your
[ __ ] cars when somebody got hurt I'm
probably reading into it wrong I'm sure
he's a great [ __ ] guy but jesus
[ __ ] christ
Oh policy genius Oh September September
is national life insurance Awareness
Month most people aren't aware of that
in fact most people aren't aware they
need life insurance at all that's why
40% of Americans don't have it but
getting life insurance doesn't need to
be difficult or expensive right now
prices are the lowest they've been in 20
years and policy genius has made it
easier than ever to get covered policy
genius is the easy way to shop for life
insurance online in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and red tape and policy genius
doesn't just make life and sure it's
easy that's a period and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they can also find you the right that
should have been the same sentence right
they could also help you find the right
home insurance and auto insurance and
disability insurance if you need life
insurance but you just haven't got
around to it
national life if you think you know
Kevin Hart but you haven't got around to
meeting them national life insurance
awareness month is as good a time as any
to get static go to policy genius calm
get quotes and apply in minutes you can
do the whole thing
your phone right now policy genius the
easiest way to compare and buy life
insurance ah our old favorites favorites
here stamps.com everybody it's the
stamps and they're at the dot-com you
know oh you know no one really has time
to go to the post office or I don't know
anybody's name down there you're busy
who's got time for all that traffic
parking lugging all your mail and
packages it's a real hassle man
that's why you need stamps calm one of
the most popular time-saving tools for
small businesses I have an old classic
card like to show you
stamps.com eliminates trips look how big
my zipper is there's a reason for that
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office simply safe wait sorry
simply use your computer sorry they use
the same word as the other coffee on my
copy I went to another [ __ ] time zone
with the advertising there use your
computer to use official to print
official US poster post it up I'm off
the [ __ ] rails Oh
dyslexia I don't have dyslexia but a lot
of people have a mild case of it simply
use your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
set once your mail is ready just hand it
to your mail carrier or drop it in a
mailbox it's that simple with stamps
calm you get five cents off every first
class stamp and up to 40% off Priority
Mail right now my / our listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bur that stamps comm enter
ber I think he was doing it because he
was trying to say these older cars can
be dangerous this is the most bizarre
[ __ ] thing ever
polyamorous boyfriend or a douchebag oh
wait a minute wait I got forgot to play
my jingle here we go
here we go come on oh I don't really
know how to sing but it doesn't stop me
from trying
alright what the [ __ ] am i let's let's
read some of this [ __ ] here
polyamorous boyfriend or douchebag
alright I got a [ __ ] look I don't
even know what polyamorous means Oh
monogamous
Metamucil I don't know where these
[ __ ] words me poly amorous definition
polyamorous demisexual polyamorous
characterized by or involved in the
practice of engaging in multiple sexual
relationships with the consent of all
the people involved yeah well in
layman's terms
living the dream oh I don't know anyone
in a polyamorous relationship but oh it
sounds like a lot of fun if you have the
right seat belt alright Paul II am a
more us what is that demisexual somebody
wants to bang to me more sex positive
demisexual demisexual our demisexuals
polyamorous - this is [ __ ] amazing
you know I was a kid it was gay and
straight that's it
that was Italy who knew there was all
these different shades and now they all
have [ __ ] names you know and it's
just gonna keep going you know they're
gonna figure out they gotta see what
kind of porn you're into and they're
gonna fab they look like new [ __ ]
labels everything alright alright what
you know I got a look what is a
demisexual a demi you need to know this
[ __ ] I'm getting [ __ ] trouble
by saying the wrong [ __ ] thing i'ma
do mu sexual that demisexual our
demisexual is a person who does not
experience sexual attraction unless they
form a strong emotional connection with
someone Jesus you know a [ __ ] someone
who is raised right it's more commonly
seen in but by no means confined to
romantic relationships it's a person who
does not experience sexual attraction
unless they form a strong emotionally
yeah that sounds like a [ __ ]
well-adjusted person all right well now
I want to know the answer to that our
demisexuals monogamous
oh my god there's grey asexual what the
[ __ ] is that is that like when you're
almost dead and you'd only if you don't
not only didn't want to [ __ ] anybody
don't want to live anymore
you [ __ ] skin's all grey I know it's
not that little gray a sexual grey
asexual spelt GRA Y a sexual is a sexual
orientation on the asexual spectrum can
you imagine the [ __ ] work asexual
people must get done provided in a
jerking off all day maybe for asexual
there's no [ __ ] you're just not in a
relationship you know no fights hey what
do you want up to dinner tonight that'd
be exactly what the [ __ ] you want
alright there's a sexual orientation on
the asexual spectrum gray of sexuals may
experience sexual attraction but very
and frequently that's crazy that's like
they give us eat like animals they like
[ __ ] once to one time a year the wired
like that some gray as sexual people may
not may only feel a sexual attraction
once or twice in their life oh my god
and then they'd just they've never given
a [ __ ] than this is there anything here
that gray is sexuals opening lines
hey I gotta tell you I really find you
attractive no you don't understand I
haven't found any but my my dick has not
gone up in [ __ ] three decades all
right it's like five six presidents some
grey asexual people won't find one sin
twice in their life others may
experience it more frequently but still
not as frequently as most a low sexual
people oh my god me this just you know
what this is like types of clouds try to
get my instrument rating on my pilot's
license and it's just like it's just
like Stratus cumulus nimblest Stratus
lentil lifting [ __ ] it's just like
jesus [ __ ] christ you know it's like
it's like the amount of of M&Ms they
have now
or a low sexuals or a low romantic is
the opposite of asexual in other words
someone who experiences sexual or
romantic attraction the term is not that
mean they [ __ ] a lot of people the term
was created by the a-spec community as a
way to describe those who are not
asexual and / or not aromantic and what
the [ __ ] is aromantic jesus christ what
where am i on the internet right now now
you know I read so many definitions I
don't want anything is what am I talking
about here polyamorous they have back to
thing
polyamorous boyfriend or douchebag well
I can already answer this well it
depends if you're [ __ ] banging a
bunch of guys and he's out there banging
a bunch of women all right lady dear
bill I have a predicament then I'm in
and I need your hilarious and brutal
brutal honesty oh you know why you know
why come on play [ __ ] I try to cue it up
come on I want to put that's me
[Music]
hey from somebody else all right I'm
gonna stop playing Nick is gonna get old
real quick I have a predicament that I
mean I need your layers proven see I'm a
27 year old lady premia life
oh yeah anybody else get the new [ __ ]
tool album how great is that huh
that's my [ __ ] right there I want to
figure that song out before I give it
and have somebody [ __ ] just look at
somebody do a [ __ ] drum chrome cover
it's called invincible or if you have my
drumming ability it's called impossible
thank you be here all week all right I'm
a 27 year old lady and I've been in a
relationship with a 25 year old guy for
about eight months now
I'll dude this guy is the [ __ ] man
he's banging an older broad and he
talked her into a polyamorous
relationship when this guy's the [ __ ]
he's smart he's loving and we spend all
of our days off together though there
have been a lot of issues along the way
that make me unsure about us when we
were three months into our relationship
my boyfriend told me about his ex who he
claims is not an ex but just someone he
casually slept with for four years
dot-dot-dot ellipses I roll he told me
he felt bad for her because she was
going through a rough time and she lost
all of her friends oh so she was getting
the consoling [ __ ] I mean that's the
thing you know you got grayish sexuals
you got demisexuals and then you got uh
consoler sexuals he asked if if it would
be okay for him to meet up with her for
a cup of coffee I said okay as I trusted
him and he reassured me he felt nothing
for her that he was not attracted to her
and that he just wanted to grab some
coffee out Jesus Christ about a week
after that conversation I called him and
he answered revealing that his ex was in
his apartment okay all right well there
you go
now what you should have done was going
out and get some hot coffee in [ __ ]
throne has faced it and the both of them
were having beers after I quickly ended
the conversation he immediately texts
texted me asking if he could [ __ ] her or
come on her tits no joke I answered him
ended the relationship and stated that
we both clearly wanted different things
lol hey even one thing about this guy
he's [ __ ] honest well I guess he
didn't say that she was coming over he
immediately sent her home he says and he
came over he was upset and explained he
was upset is this real you [ __ ] with
me
he was upset and explained that he
thought we were in a polyamorous
relationship now he didn't know we
didn't know we didn't this is the way he
does this [ __ ] this is what I think the
kids call gaslighting even though I told
him that he could not have sex with
anyone else when we agreed to be
boyfriend / girlfriend there was only
one conversation of a poly Amory in
which he did say he wanted to be in a
polyamorous relationship but I responded
to this by asking him what a polyp Oh
what polyamory even was and he said that
it meant that maybe we could have a
threesome
I answered maybe someday yeah so this
guy's a lying piece of [ __ ]
but I wasn't ready for that he was okay
with that never mentioned that we could
[ __ ] whoever we wanted when we wanted
after much fighting we end up working
through it he admitted that he was in
love with me now [ __ ] he's keeping
you in his stable [ __ ] this guy and that
polyamory was not important to him at
all [ __ ] oh I don't know this guy
but um I would break up with him that he
would rather be with me than with all
the ladies in the world no bullsh
I'm sure he said that so that chick he
was having [ __ ] beers with he agreed
not to talk to his ex anymore and we
moved on that's all [ __ ] since then
we discussed boundaries many times I've
tried to end the relationship a couple
more times because of his ignorant
flirtatious behavior he's not ignorant
he's selfish found out he went out
for a drink with a girl from class he's
attracted to and found out he's been
texting her though not sexually yeah
Jesus Christ how many more red flags do
you need most recently I tried to break
up with him after he told me he was
texting his ex again yeah I called that
[ __ ] two paragraphs ago every time we
fight I try to end it he writes me long
letters about how much he loves me and
would do anything for me he's full of
[ __ ] he's just he's just saying whatever
he needs to say to selfishly keep you in
his life it's gonna feel [ __ ] great
tell us got to go [ __ ] himself
I don't even know this guy and I hate
this guy he'll blame his behavior and
his terrible relationship with his
mother and his father he'll do anything
but take responsibility for it he blames
his father who was a womanizer he begs
me to give him time and to tell him what
it is and isn't okay yeah because he
doesn't get it what was what you should
do you should invite him over one time
as you're riding the dick of somebody
else you'd be like you see this this
isn't okay if you see what you're
feeling right now that's how you've been
make that's how you were making me feel
he literally wrote out a relationship
agreement my friends don't like him and
think he is a controlling he's
controlling slash disrespectful towards
him I never met the guy and I don't like
him
they say I'm Way out of mud up they say
I'm way out of his League and they are
shocked that he acts the way he does all
they say I'm Way out of his League okay
I know the answer seems obvious but I'm
deeply in love with him yeah he's
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you is what's
happening here that's what it is he's a
good-looking guy and this is how he gets
away with it right that's what it is
I get it I see I was wondering why you
would stay with this person I get it now
all right he's coming over there you
know he's got the romantic novel hair
you know he's packing about eight inches
he knows what to do with it and he keeps
sucking you back in but telling myself
he's just young and naive I always
believed him when he says he'll stop
talking to other girls and that he's
never that he has never cheated on me as
I can see how much he loves me
parentheses as I've read through his
text yeah they probably copied and
pasted
from the other person he said him too
though it hasn't changed how much he
looks at other girls how much he loves
strip clubs oh good lord
and how about cocaine can we throw that
in there for the trifecta and the fact
that I have to even read through his
text please bill am I just blind because
I love or does this relationship just
need a lot of work in communication
longtime fan and listener best wishes to
you Nia and your lovely daughter and of
course go [ __ ] yourself yeah yeah Jesus
Christ you know what I bet as I read
this out loud you know I think you know
what you need to do yeah [ __ ] this guy
it [ __ ] this guy and this guy is gonna
hurt a lot of people and so analogue ear
with them the more he's gonna hurt you
get the [ __ ] out that's it alright
that's it Oh what I would do
alright boyfriends hot ex help dear bill
and Nia I gotta have her on here more
time once we had the kid it's hard cuz
you know she's got to make sure she's
all right as I run out go do the podcast
I'll have to figure a way around this
alright I'm a huge fan but I had a
[ __ ] babysitter to have her on my
puckish I'm a huge fan of the podcast
thank you thank you for delivering uncut
t blunt advice alright well you all
skies also know that oh I don't know if
I ever took a psychology class I've been
with my boyfriend for three years now I
love him to death we live together
bought a car together why why would you
buy a car together don't do [ __ ] like
that unless you're married and planned
vacations every six months
I'm a 35 year old lady and he's 33
don't shoot me for this but this has a
lot to do with why I'm worried we
started messing around when he was
already in a long-term relationship my
boyfriend I used to work together and I
would see his girlfriend at the time
bringing him food etc back then she was
overweight from what I've heard she was
incredibly insecure I've also heard
stories from his friends that she wasn't
the most supportive person it was too
immature being as she was six years
younger than him okay so this is the
information about the ex that's
to make you feel like he's not gonna die
here's the issue as a month ago as of a
month ago he started going on this
health kick he got a gym membership and
started wearing new Cologne I didn't
think oh boy
I didn't think hey you know what that's
that's pretty good that's pretty good
investigative work there props to you I
didn't think anything of it until Monday
Labor Day
I don't usually stall I don't usually
snoop but when I do but I went onto our
laptop for my own personal use his
Facebook was still open and I went
through his messages about mid June I
found a group conversation with three of
his friends telling him how his hot his
ex had gotten when I logged out of his
account to log into mine I found out
that he created a face face fake
facebook profile under the search
history I found her profile alright
Jesus Christ these are two in the same
that night I made a comment about
joining a gym - because I've gained a
little weight I've gained a little love
power I figured we could go work out
together he was really supportive but
directed me to all the location patients
he does not go to he doesn't know that I
know which one he works out at I feel
like I'm being played and lied to am I
being paranoid should I say something to
him no no you're not you're not being
paranoid yeah you got a dump this guy or
you got to call him out on it you guys
can work through it one of the other
alright that's it you know that's that's
it but that all of that behavior is yeah
something's going on and you know you
can work to it you know I've been on
both sides of that coin throughout my
[ __ ] history should I drop out of
college dear Billy Berg I am a 19 year
old college student at Wittenberg
University it's a small College like a
half an hour from wish this person lives
I've been seriously thinking about
dropping out
school at the end of the year and trying
to find a job slice internship or just
start my own business alright well I
like what you're thinking you want to
work for yourself that's always a good
thing I'm not dropping out because the
classes are too hard or anything like
that it's just college doesn't seem like
the place for me I think I can really do
well for myself without obtaining my
bachelor's degree I also already have my
associates degree I think at this point
college is almost just a waste of money
and the only reason why I'm in college
right now is because I'm swimming and my
parents really want me to get a degree I
also have some money saved up that I
could use for a few months while I wait
to find a job my dream job has always
been to be a general manager of a sports
team or just be a decision maker in a
front office but that is very far out
there no one is Indian 19 you know what
every general manager in sports you know
what you know what they were at some
point they were 19 and weren't in the
NFL or in baseball MLB why the [ __ ]
can't you do that if I can [ __ ] tell
jokes for a living you gonna be a
general manager don't think that way
alright go after [ __ ] like that until
you know until actually trying tell us
you know and it'll tell you I would I
couldn't wear it that way just [ __ ]
go for it because this is a thing even
if you fall short you gotta be working
in some capacity in sports and it's
gonna be [ __ ] awesome alright general
manager go sports team okay I know that
I have the skills to succeed in life and
my parents and others don't see that I'm
sure they see it but their parents and
they want you to have that degree
because parents worried that you're
gonna be homeless if you don't have a
college degree if you think I should bet
on myself and drop out of college do you
have any advice for me in the real world
thank you I love the podcasts and go
[ __ ] yourself this is what I do there's
a way to do both because I knew that my
parents wanted me to finish college and
I wanted to finish college and I already
started being a comedian so what I
did was I just took classes in the night
I went out and I [ __ ] did stand-up so
I was already doing what the [ __ ] I
wanted to do so if there's a way for you
to start you jumpstart your dream before
there's a way to do that I'm not saying
don't drop out I mean you're gonna have
to make this decision but and I agree
with you especially the way the economy
is and all of that stuff and I don't
speak about this because I don't know
how important or how unimportant having
a college degree is back in the day when
I was one of the last generations where
they actually gave a [ __ ] where you went
to college but now it just seems like
you know motivated kids can get together
come up with a [ __ ] idea and create a
goddamn app and make a ton of money and
I know that's very [ __ ] rare that's
like when I started out you write a
stand-up act then they turn it into a
sitcom and then you make half a billion
dollars I mean the reality was like 10
comics that happened to so I don't know
exactly what your game plan is so but I
mean you do have your associate's degree
you sound like you had your head screwed
on straight and a lot of unbelievably
successful people dropped out of college
also another bunch of people who never
did [ __ ] with their life dropped out of
college so I don't know what the [ __ ]
this is like this is a big one you got
to you got to make this decision
yourself but oh by the way can I go back
here if this person took the time to
make a fake facebook profile [ __ ] that
that's hardcore that's hard it's not
like they just met somebody got drunk
and [ __ ] [ __ ] around that's like
like CIA level [ __ ] around
definitely don't don't try to work it
out with that person all right back to
the zone should I drop out of college
yeah you got to make that decision for
yourself but I think what you're
thinking about doing is great because
you want to go after a dream and the
fact that you you already want to do
that at 19 shows a lot of balls I didn't
have the balls to do it till I was
almost 24 so you're like almost five
years ahead of me
my math is correct so there's a number
of ways to do what you want to do you
can drop out just do it you could start
your dream jump started continue going
to college you could fast-forward
through college go right through the
summertime and do it in three years
because you want to get out in the real
world then you get the degree your
parents are [ __ ] happy and then get on
with it there's a bunch of you have all
the options in the world at 19 you know
there you go so just don't get involved
in a [ __ ] relationship with somebody
who wants you to [ __ ] stay home every
night rather than work on your dream
alright that's it stay away from drugs
alright charisma hey Billy needs a new
vice big fan love the plugin okay I need
some advice
that will help me progress in my career
I've been told more than once than a
very talented in my field but in order
to move up the old corporate lay here's
the rule if you actually say I need some
advice then you get this song alright
bill I need some excitement yes okay
that will help me in my career
I've been told that more than once that
I'm very talented in my field but in
order to move up the old corporate
ladder here I will need to develop more
charisma and stage presence stage
presence
I guess what to give presentations an
introvert by nature and I'm more
comfortable in smaller group settings
where I know at least one person I need
to become the guy that people are
excited to hear speak at a conference
I've heard you talk about bombing on
stage in the past and I'd love your
thoughts about on how to practice
charisma and presence thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself I don't know that you you can't
practice charisma and the [ __ ] is that
oh it's more music it's kind of cool
every time I play that I play a little
bit of the tool album you can't practice
charisma and come and in presence but
what like that's just whatever you were
born with those are gifts but they can
also be buried what you can practice is
being comfortable so a lot of bringing
out your personality is being
comfortable and right now you're not
comfortable so you're in between your
ears when you go up there and you're not
relaxed and the crowd feeds off of you
if you're up there and you're nervous
you're gonna make them nervous or
uncomfortable or not want to listen to
what you're saying so what I would do is
the only thing I'd say is what I did was
when I was in college I just any
opportunity to get up in front of the
class to do a presentation to do a
little performance anything I could do
to get up there and each time I got more
and more confident it's really not that
big a deal it's just a weird experience
it's just a different experience you
know learning to speak in front of a
group is no different than learning how
to [ __ ] skate or [ __ ] hit a ball
or something like that you just have to
do it play a guitar you know learned you
just gotta go down and [ __ ] play
every night and one day you know how to
play a guitar just keep getting up in
front of people and make little goals if
you're introverted that's what you need
you need tiny goals that will be
positive like the first goal
justbe I'm getting up in front of
somebody this week I'm getting up in
front of a group of people this week
don't have any sort of pressure on how
well you have to do all you got to do is
get up in a second you get up then boom
that's a positive I remember when I used
to do stand-up shows in rooms that I was
afraid of you know especially I was
doing those Uptown shows when I was when
I would be like the only [ __ ] white
guy in the room I would be like Jesus
Christ and sometimes I would chicken out
and I would go home and I would feel
terrible that I that I chicken down and
then I would just be and then the next
week I would I remember I went back down
there and I was thinking about you know
running home again and then I was just
like all right what's gonna feel worse
going up and bombing but no one you
tried or going home not trying and
laying there and feeling like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] so that's all it was so when I
would started to do any time I did you
know some sort of show you know in a
[ __ ] up environment all it was about
was having the balls to go up there when
they called my name and whatever
happened happened I didn't beat myself
up over the performance at least I
learned to not do that so I'll give you
that advice right out of the gate I hope
you use it all right and and what's
gonna happen is the more you do it the
more comfortable you get then your
personality comes out your personality
comes out then there's your presence
there's who you are and there's all
different kinds of presence and charisma
from [ __ ] soup megawatt [ __ ] movie
star
- nerd charisma self-deprecating making
fun of yourself talking about our
awkward or whatever like that although
I'm not a big fan of saying that you're
awkward you know when you're up there
just be yourself get over it [ __ ] man
up even if you're an art just be a
[ __ ] man alright
or a woman whatever you are alright
overrated underrated overrated trying to
get a spot close to the entrance of the
grocery store oh yeah [ __ ] waste of
time all right there you spend more time
looking for this spot than it would take
to walk from the back of the lot
and most of the people can use a few
extra step on the old Fitbit
exactly it's good for you underrated
free samples at the grocery store it's
so hard to find nowadays that when I do
I have a dinners worth that's awesome
yeah I like that overrated day drinking
I love day drinking all right dead back
in the day this always sounds like such
a fantastic idea on paper grab
somebody's some beers and say [ __ ]
responsibility for a day or even better
do it by yourself but in reality there's
only two possibly equally shitty
outcomes either you end up so shitcan
from hours of day boozing that you have
the brilliant idea to say hey let's go
to the bar so now you're already wanged
when you start the night boozing well
I'll commend you that I mean I usually
start at the bar that's why I used to do
what I would do it at the [ __ ] bar
and then that was it I just be laughs at
my balls off like I can't believe I'm
this drunk at [ __ ] 12:30 in the
afternoon
you're so Wang when you start boozing
you black out at 6 p.m. and make an ass
of yourself at some shitty drunk well
you're not supposed to drink the whole
[ __ ] night I would just drink it
after 3-4 hours of it I would be [ __ ]
shit-faced and I would go home the my
biggest problem was that I'd pass out
and I'd wake up at midnight I already
have gotten eight hours sleep and it
throws them all my sleep off we've
finished reading this person's here you
know making you're an asset yourself at
some shitty drunk food diner at 8 p.m.
and sleep on someone else's couch then
you wake up in the morning with many
missed calls and angry texts and have to
piece together your life to figure out
who you need to tuck your tail and
apologize to or so the second outcome
you act responsible and quit drinking
before evening rolls around but then
have to live with sobering up while
awake getting hungover before bedtime
and end up sweating through your sheets
and sleeping with a headache
well I mean that kind of happens if you
go to a football game during the day
right
know when your date drink day drinking
is for pros I go and then I go and buy I
used to like you going by yourself
you sit down you order the drink and
then the bartender knows he's here at
this time this is his drink and then all
you do he just walks by you're not the
same thing you just tap your glass or
just point and then that's it
and he just [ __ ] keep serving you
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang just
like that like mister [ __ ] blunt and
then you go home and you go to sleep you
don't do it all the time but you know
what I get it it's over it so don't I
would do it if you don't like it then
don't do it that's what I say if you
don't like it don't [ __ ] do it oh I
don't know who does podcast I don't know
what it is alright that's it you know
what I hear actually heard from a friend
of mine who actually went and uh I'm not
even going to talk about it I'm going to
talk about but everything's good
everything's fine alright that's it okay
that's the podcast everybody go [ __ ]
yourselves
I will check in on you on Thursday and
by the way well who's the Monday night
game I'm gonna be doing a bunch of
[ __ ] media to this week all right
I'll be on the Joe Rogan podcast I'll be
on Tom papa
unfortunate FEM stirrers podcast I got
what else Theo von maybe next week I
know I had to move that one Jimmy Kimmel
show and a bunch of other places and
then eventually I'll do a week of press
in New York City I mean I can't [ __ ]
thank you guys enough for all the times
you that you've watched my specials I
hope you watch this one again because
that's why I get to live my dream so
thank you so much I'm so proud of this
special and I'm so thankful that I
somehow I got to thank Conan O'Brien who
put me on his show to do
panel that's how Mike binder and saw me
the first time that's how I ended up in
one of his movies and that's how in the
end he ended up [ __ ] no wait his
friend clay told him that I was on the
Conan show that's what it is I got so
many people to [ __ ] thank here and
now I shot my special it looks
un-fuckin'-believable
I only only hope my material
doesn't [ __ ] him out of the whatever
award he should be getting for how he
shot this [ __ ] thing cuz it's
absolutely gorgeous all right that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in on you
on Thursday